always all right we're going to draft
the most intriguing characters for the
coming week
anyone you want peter you get to go
first
i'll say number one will be shaq barrett
and you know i think
the tampa bay buccaneers have made a
very
calculated decision in not placing
the franchise tag on shaq barrett for
the second time
and that calculated decision basically
is that look
the password there's a lot of pass
rushers in this market
and we are hoping that nobody goes out
on a limb
and pays shaq barrett 18 19 million a
year
because we really want him back
so to me this is a calculated risk
and and to me i when i look at all the
guys who the bucks
needed to bring back this year shaq
barrett in my opinion was more important
than chris godwin they have depth at the
receiver position
they don't have young depth or depth for
the next two or three years
at the pass rush position and peter if
all else fails with all these other pass
rushers that are available in free
agency this year and there are plenty
you could go out and get maybe two
or more or get somebody else with the
money that you would spend on shaq
barrett
and shaq barrett was a value free agent
a couple of years ago
that that jason light and the buccaneers
found so
i think at a certain level you have to
have the confidence you can find a
replacement
for a lot less that's what this is about
you're right
yep yeah for me it's urban meyer
because here's a guy who's got and we
just talked last segment about all the
cap space the jaguars have
he's new to the nfl we've seen a minor
misadventure
maybe a major misadventure with the
hiring and then the quick resignation of
chris doyle
how is urban meyer going to handle
himself with all this money to spend
it's not recruiting like it used to be
you have to bring the cash who's he
going to be able to lure to jacksonville
especially once the first wave goes by
after the first couple of days
how can he convince guys to pick the
jaguars over other teams
urban meyer i think is going to be a
very fascinating individual good bad or
otherwise over the next few days
my next one's going to be joe douglas
and and mike
you know the the fans of new york and
the tabloids of new york
don't want to hear when you've got 69
million dollars of cap room
and there's a lot of good players in
this market they don't want to hear
hey listen when we've spent a jillion
dollars on free agents in recent years
it never goes well did it go well with
le'veon bell
no you know did it go well with cj
mosley
no but i think now this
year i think the jets are going to say
there's one or two players
that we really think we can get better
by trying to sign and maybe overpaying a
little bit
i don't think joe douglas is going to go
crazy but i do
think he's going to dip his toe into the
first two or three days of free agency
and go out and get at least one guy for
pretty good money
i'm gonna stay with another gm and i'm
gonna go to chicago where ryan pace has
a quarterback decision to make
is he going to try to go all in to get
himself
russell wilson could desean watson be
persuaded
to make the bears a destination would
chicago try to get
deshawn from houston what are they going
to do at quarterback is trubisky going
to be back could nick foles be traded to
philadelphia this is a complete
open slate for the chicago bears at the
quarterback position
and ryan pace has his job in many
respects riding on this next decision he
makes at quarterback peter
yeah you know one of the ones that i'm
curious about and i don't even know
that this team is gonna do anything
about this position
but i think it's interesting to watch
what sean payton
and mickey loomis do in new orleans
because
we're not positive that it's jameis
winston taysom hill
we think it probably is but we don't
know that for sure
and i'll be curious to see what are the
signs
because even if they do absolutely
nothing
in free agency you can read the tea
leaves and say
aha they're not doing anything for the
rest of their team
because they know the rest of their team
is okay they're not happy about losing
trey hendrickson
a really good young pass rusher they're
not happy about that
but this offseason they believe is going
to be about
taking their best shot at either the
best quarterback they can get
or to kind of retrench and to build
around these two quarterbacks for this
year
and you know i had on my list drew brees
i'm not going to pick brees because i
think it fits with yours but brees
hovers over this as well
we are more than five weeks removed from
when sean payton said on this show
we're a week or a week and a half away
from getting an answer on drew brees we
still haven't gotten one
and it becomes more conspicuous and more
awkward if he hasn't announced his
retirement
before the start of the league here
where they have to go out and possibly
re-sign jameis winston
and if they re-sign jameis winston
there's no room at the end
for drew brees at that point but then
brees could walk through the door and
say
hey i'm only under contract for a
million bucks why isn't there a spot for
me
so i think he the to the extent that he
continues to hover
unresolved over the saints that's
fascinating as well my next pick is
gonna be david tepper we talked about
him earlier in the show the panthers
owner wants a franchise quarterback
needs a franchise quarterback and is
determined to get a franchise
quarterback
is he going to implement a plan to get
to sean watson this week what is he
going to do with teddy bridgewater is he
going to try to make a run of
russell wilson and he can't help himself
he's motivated to get that franchise
quarterback and i think we're going to
see the panthers do something
significant at least in an effort to get
one in the course of the next week
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports